The jogan Experience imagine the
research that could go into that with
that budget and you go look you're not
going to win the war on drugs you don't
even like there's prisons high security
category a prisons and they've got drugs
in them you can't even keep the drugs
out of there good luck with the
borders yeah it's it strikes me as like
you go just admit you're not going to
win that fight right and what are we
going to do and that best practice of
going well that's going on in Portugal
now they've done a 15-year test case we
know it works I mean Lisbon now have you
been to Lisbon no you go Lisbon yeah
food is I mean I mean the Portuguese
it's fabulous such a great City such a
great City Lisbon and Porto I mean I
don't really know the rest of Portugal
that well but it's they're both
phenomenal places to play gigs and they
love stand-up comedy it's just a Wonder
crazy that little country was like
Conquering the world at one point in
time sorry I'm from Great Britain hi hi
hi yeah you Dido we had a great run
wasn't bad we I tell you what we used to
own
this sort of crazy yeah crazy right it
is crazy it's crazy how Empires rise and
fall and that's one of the things that
people are wondering currently about
America if we're in the last throws of a
Dying Empire well here's M I got a hot
take on this please I don't think they
do so I don't think the Roman Empire
fell I think it became a church
I think the so the the Rome fell but the
Roman Empire became the church where's
all the money from the Roman Empire the
Vatican in the basement of the Vatican
is where it is yeah that's that's I
don't think the British the Vatican yeah
it's incredible bizarre it's incredible
a city within a city the wealth the the
sheer wealth in art is overwhelming yeah
like St Peter's Basilica when I walked
in there I my mouth was open the entire
time I was there
like you just can't believe the amount
of craftsmanship the architecture the
art the painting well I mean if you
think about culturally what happened
every song every painting was about God
until 100 years ago and now every song's
about love I think they're talking about
the same thing but that's me being an
old so Roman Empire became a church
British Empire became a bank ooh so we
gave our Empire back we said oh yeah
sorry we sorry about that you can have
that back uh we gave you know Saudi
Arabia back and what all these other
places that we'd sort of we taking the
resources and then they had their own
money and then we then we went oh well
what are you what are you doing with
that money because we've got this thing
called the city of London what I tell
you what it's your money but we're going
to hold it we we'll have it over here is
that okay yeah fine great so we've still
got that thing of like and culturally
I think you know America is I mean
America's extraordinary it's an
extraordinary place it's kind of based
on this amazing premise it it strikes me
that America is um
uh it's better
now
objectively than it has ever been and
subjectively worse than it's ever
been so you go the the experience it
seems bad but objectively when you look
at the metrics it's good so that's kind
of Steven Pinker thing but I mean
subjectivity is important like people
aren't people feel like they're at War
MH and actually this is the the land of
milk and honey you know it's it's uh and
I think it's still got a bit of that
thing of like
the you know Austin Texas maybe has it
as much as anywhere it's it's it's
Whispering you know go and be yourself
yeah the pursuit of happiness it's still
got that kind of that that dream well
I'm always fascinated how people from
other parts of the world see
it that's what's interesting when
someone comes here and they just like
look around like I had the trigonometry
guys here the other day oh yeah yeah and
Francis and const Constantine and when
we were here and we we were coming to
the club they were like mate this place
is incredible like the just the freedom
that you guys have and the the the
wildness that's in the air like it's so
it's so intoxicating and exciting like
this is something something's really
happening here well you know it's that
it's a beacon it's always been a bit of
a beacon America because it's kind of
founded on an idea and you know it's
that it's it Devil's in the detail I
always think of the Statue of Liberty
you ever SE there's a thing in in Paris
in the uh the Muse D there's the model
they made a model of the because it was
crowdfunded the the Statue of Liberty it
was a gift from the people of France to
the people of America right kind of
post-revolution and they thought this a
good idea yeah get we'll get them
something nice we'll get them a nice
statue so they funded It the French
people gave money and the think when you
see it when you see the model of the
Statue of Liberty you realize she's not
just carrying a torch she's walking
forward you realize she's moving forward
and it kind of changes it
yeah yeah it's it's you know there
there'll be I think there's potential
for I
mean I think America hasn't seen its
finest days yet I would I would hope I
would hope as I mean Britain has to find
a new place in the world but you know
the brexit and everything happened we
need to find you know it's purpose like
I think with people with
nations with with the world it's like
finding purpose is very important yeah
and what's the next you know purpose
going to be how are we going to fit in
what's our place going to
be